When you look at your voting record
and the issues
that are important to you
as spelled out on your website,
most of them are traditional
democratic issues.
Capital, Capital, D,
expanding health care, access,
abortion rights, LGBTQ rights,
path for Dreamers, and on and on.
Environmentalism, green energy.
That sounds like a Democrat to me.
No.
Well, I know this is really hard
for a lot of folks, especially in D.C..
But what's important to me is to not be
to not be tethered by the Partizanship
that dominates politics today.
And I think Americans are tired of it.
I think Arizonans are tired of it.
What I'm interested in
is working
on all those issues
that you just mentioned
that I care deeply about
and that I believe
my constituents care deeply about.
But I want to work on them
in a way that is productive,
that is free, from the trappings
of the pull of the political system.
You know, the national political parties
have pulled our politics farther
to the edges than I've ever seen.
I want to
remove some of that
kind of that poison from our politics.
I want to get back to actually
just working on the issues,
working together to try and solve
these challenges.
And one of the big complaints
I hear from conservatives,
from Republicans, is Democrats
just don't take border
security seriously.
They just don't
Do you agree with that sentiment?
And do you think there is an actual
path forward there?
Democrats are still going
to have the majority in the next Senate
you can still get this
on the floor of the Senate if you want.
Well, as a native Arizonan
who was born
and raised near the southern border,
I can tell you unequivocally
that the federal government has failed
its duty
in the last 40 years,
not just Democrats,
not it's just everyone.
The federal government has failed here.
And places
like Arizona
on the front lines of this crisis
have been paying the price
every single day since then.
So for us, this isn't just a talking
point of team versus TV.
This is our life every day.
The reality is, is that when folks say,
you know,
we've got to just provide a legal path
to citizenship, for Dreamers,
which I support wholeheartedly.
These kids are Americans in all but name.
So when folks say, we've got to do that,
I agree.
And when folks say
we've got to secure the border,
of course I agree.
You know,
my state is suffering
from the failure to do so for 40 years.
So this is a perfect example of why
I'm so frustrated with Partizanship
that has gripped our nation.
And the parties are pulling folks away.
It's not either or.
It's and
both of
those concerns are real and valid.
And we as a government
have a duty to solve
both of those concerns.
You're up for reelection in 20, 24.
This move means,
I suppose, that you're not
going to be running
in the Democratic primary
for the Senate seat.
Well, again,
I know
this will probably
be disappointing to folks,
but I'm actually not even thinking
about electoral politics
or talking about that at all right now.
But doesn't
this increase the likelihood
that your run for reelection
will be tougher
because you will not only have
a Republican opponent,
you may even have a Democratic opponent?
You know, I
don't make decisions based on what
the easy road or the tough road is.
I have always tried to make decisions
based on what I think is right.
And for me, it's very important
that we have a discussion
at home in Arizona
and here in the nation's capital
about reducing the partizanship
and just focus on solving the challenges
that we face in America.
The challenges we face are great.
They're significant.
We cannot solve them
by using partizan attacks.
through a partizan lens.
And I want to be a part
of having that discussion
and showing
that there is a different way.
Would you ever run for president?
No, never. I don't want to be president.
There are two independents
who already caucus
with the Democrats, Bernie
Sanders of Vermont and Angus
King of Maine.
Lisa Murkowski,
who's a Republican
but ran
in a previous election as an independent
is also,
you know, somebody who
whose independence is now noted.
Are the
are those three models at all
for what you're doing?
Are there other independents
Teddy Roosevelt in the Bull Moose Party?
Is there anyone you look to
as a as a guide,
as a mentor, as a role model
when it comes to what you're doing?
You Jake,
it probably won't surprise you
when I tell you
I'm not trying to be like anyone else.
What I'm trying to do is be true
to my values and the values of my state.
So you know,
I think
everyone should make their own decisions
about where they fit
or where they don't fit.
I'm going to keep doing
exactly what I do,
which is just stay focused on the work,
you know, and ignore all the noise
Here with me now
is somebody
who knows a thing or two
about going his own way.
Independent Senator
Bernie Sanders of Vermont.
Senator, first, you are an independent.
She is now the third
official independent of the U.S.
Senate, joining
you and Angus King of Maine.
What do you think of her decision
and also what
you just heard in her interview?
With Jake
I don't want to spend a whole lot of time
on Senator Cinema.
She has her reasons, Don.
I happen to suspect that
it's probably a lot to do
with politics back in Arizona.
I think
the Democrats
there are not all that enthusiastic
about somebody who helped sabotage
some of the most important legislation
that protects the interests
of working families and voting rights
and so forth.
So I think it really has to do with her
political aspirations
for the future in Arizona.
But for us,
I think nothing much has changed
in terms
of the functioning of the US Senate.
The good news is that we now have
51 votes,
we'll have majority on committees.
That means that we can go forward
and start protecting the interests
of the working families
to deal with the reality
that we are increasing things.
Living in an oligarchy
where the billionaire class
and large corporations
control
almost every aspect of our country.
So I would hope very much
that with this new majority,
Democrats will sit down and start
fighting for the needs
of ordinary Americans.
So I want to talk about
some of those issues in a second.
But first,
you were a very important
figure on the campaign
trail for progressives
ahead of the midterms,
as you normally are.
I'm sure you're going to be campaigning
for candidates in 20, 20
for the outgoing
Arizona Democratic Party official.
One of them says that
he expects
Democrats will run their own candidate
against her.
Is that a good idea?
Would you support a Democratic opponent
against Senator Cinema? I don't.
I support
progressive candidates
all over this country,
people who have the guts to take
on powerful special interests.
I don't know what's
going to be happening in Arizona.
We'll see who they nominate.
But certainly
that's something I will take a hard
look at.
Does she have the guts to take
on powerful special interests?
No, she doesn't.
She has a corporate Democrat
who has, in fact,
along with Senator Manchin,
sabotaged
enormously important legislation.
I want to talk about a major deadline
to fund the government.
That is Friday.
There's still no deal.
Would you support
another short term
extension instead of a larger
bill to fund the government
and how worried are you about
the government?
Well, short term
short term extensions are just
a temporary solution
to the ongoing crisis we face.
Are clearly what I worry about
is Republican efforts
to hold hostage next year.
If we don't get an omnibus bill passed
to hold or hold hostage
the government
in order to cut Social Security,
Medicare and Medicaid,
and that,
I will vigorously oppose
you and a lot of seniors out there.
We're not making it on
Social Security today.
A lot of working people of
who are approaching retirement,
who have nothing in the bank.
I don't want to see Social Security
or Medicare cut.
I will oppose that vigorously.
You know, while I have you,
you've been in Congress a long time.
The House before the Senate, there
certainly have been some notable
bipartisan pieces of legislation
that have passed
and been signed into law,
but arguably funding the government is
up there,
maybe even the top responsibility
of you
and your fellow members of Congress.
Why does this keep happening?
Well, I think it's happening right now
because Republicans
see it as an opportunity
to hold us hostage
and get demands
that under normal circumstances
they would not
look they have
not been shy about making it clear
they want to cut Social Security,
they want to cut Medicare,
they want to cut Medicaid.
And what they're saying is, hey,
we are prepared
to allow
the United States government
to default on our payments,
bring the entire world
perhaps into an economic crisis center
unless you give us what you want.
What you're saying about the differences
right now.
But over the past
many years, Democrats
and Republicans in charge
funding
the government has just not happened.
And we've been at this crisis
point at the end of.
At the end of the year, so,
so many times.
But I want to move on to
a couple more issues
that I know that you care about.
One is
the record breaking $858 billion defense
funding bill.
The House passed that this week.
The Senate is going to vote on it.
You voted against the NDAA,
the defense bill last time around.
Will you do so again?
Yes, I think I will.
Look, we have
we have 85 million Americans
who have no health insurance.
We have 600,000 people who are homeless.
We have a dysfunctional health
care system,
dysfunctional childcare system.
Working parents are paying $15,000
a year on average for child care.
We have got to start protecting the needs
of working families.
The Pentagon is the one
major agency of government
which has never been
independently audited.
There is massive waste and fraud
and cost overruns within that agency.
So I think we can have the strong defense
that we need
without spending the huge amount of money
that we're currently spending
on the military.